bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 week-end tout de suite le
sommaire de ce vendredi 22 janvier
valérie jose chef de choeur de
l'ensemble vocal de saint quentin en
yvelines et caen plateau nous évoquerons
les 20 ans de l'ensemble vocal et leur
prochain concert dimanche 24 janvier à
l'église saint victor de guyancourt
pierre richir présente une exposition la
médiathèque saint-exupéry de
voisins-le-bretonneux jusqu'au 27
février entre abstraction et figuratif
il questionne la condition humaine sur
le thème du labyrinthe nous rejoindront
dans quelques instants en plateau claude
chose président de l'uar 16 et marie
louise bernard pour annoncer le résultat
du dernier concours photo un sourire
pour 2016 alors avec nous en plateau je
le disais valérie josse bonjour chef de
choeur de l'ensemble vocal de saint
quentin en yvelines merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
donc c'est un ensemble vocal qui a été
créée en 1995 il est composé d'une
trentaine de chanteurs et votre
répertoire alterne entre sacré et
profane c'est ça c'est exactement ça
nous avons la chance d'avoir plusieurs
programmations dans l'année et comme ça
nous ne nous spécialisons pas ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre mais nous faisons les
deux ce qui nous ravit et en accordant
une importance particulière au
répertoire contemporain
oui tout à fait nouvelles horizons le
répertoire contemporain depuis le début
on peut imaginer que un hacker qui ne
ferait pas de la musique actuelle
ben mon dieu raterait quand même une
grosse partie du prison donc nous sommes
donc présents et inclus sur cette ville
nouvelle pour favoriser la musique
contemporaine
alors vous êtes vraiment à la recherche
d'une production de qualité parce que
vous répéter une fois par semaine vous
avez des cours de technique vocale et
chaque année différentes master class
sont animés par des chefs extérieur
exactement
en fait c'est bien d'avoir un chef de
choeur qui tient la route toute l'année
mais c'est vrai que l'ensemble vocal de
saint quentin c'est aussi le partage
avec d'autres chefs
par exemple cette année nous allons être
en résidence au théâtre de saint quentin
et nous en revenons à le voir la chance
de travailler avec laurent cuniot qui
est un chef très reconnu dans le milieu
de la musique qui va nous apporter
énormément au niveau du travail musical
donc ça permet de partager sa passion
d'avoir un regard extérieur pour
approfondir l expertise c'est ça
exactement regarde bien évidemment avec
des professionnels donc qui ont
l'habitude de monter des gros projets et
qui nous entraîne avec leur fougue
habituelle
alors vous vous produisez régulièrement
sur différentes scènes est alors votre
prochaine date sera dimanche 24 janvier
à 16 heures à l'église saint victor de
guyancourt vous représenterez la petite
messe solennelle de rossini et on en
écoute tout de suite un extrait
coc
alors valérie jose pourquoi avoir choisi
la petite messe solennelle de rossini
tout d'abord parce que c'est un
répertoire que l'ensemble vocal m
c'est très vocal évidemment la musique
italienne et c'est à la croisée des deux
chemins c'est une musique sacrée certes
mais comme le disait aussi dit lui même
je mets ces propos entre guillemets
c'est une sacrée musique c'est à dire
c'est une musique avec toute sa verve
tout son contenu bien évidemment c'était
un grand amateur d'opéra et il en a
écrit beaucoup et donc ses taux à la
croisée des deux chemins et vis-à-vis de
nos 20 ans c'est une pièce qui est
vraiment représentatif de du répertoire
qu'on aime et le fait de se produire
dans un espace sacré une église est ce
qu'il ya une émotion particulière
évidemment on est très proche du
spirituel et comme toute spiritualité ça
élève l'âme et ça élève l'âme de ceux
qui la chante mais aussi de ceux qui
viennent la voir très bien m'a écouté
vous êtes tous invités donc à venir
retrouver l'ensemble vocal de saint
quentin en yvelines dimanche 24 janvier
à 16 heures à l'église saint victor de
guyancourt valérie jos merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et un très beau
concert alors avec grand plaisir
tout de suite les directions la
médiathèque de saint-exupéry de
voisins-le-bretonneux ou pierre richir
présente jusqu'au 27 février une
exposition entre abstraction et
figuratif images de patrick jacques de
dixmude poussé à l'introspection par la
peinture créer des chocs visuels
propulser le spectateur dans un univers
de questionnement sur la condition
humaine et le monde contemporain
c'est tout l'enjeu de l'exposition de
pierre richir un travail mené autour de
la thématique du labyrinthe la plus
ancienne référence c'est celle de
de la littérature grecque on trouve dans
le 10è et puis après il ya l'histoire du
minotaure et c'est donc selon la légende
il situe en crète c'est un roi qui a
construit un labyrinthe et il jette des
condamnés qui vont se faire dévorer ou
pas par le minotaure le jeu c'est de ne
pas recourir de faire un parcours et de
trouver une sortie rentrer dans un monde
on le parcours et on cherche une sortie
des personnages placé à la frontière de
deux mondes une peinture à l'huile pour
la finesse une démarche d'abstraction
introduite dans ses peintures
figuratives et des techniques réfléchie
par sept anciens élèves d'arts appliqués
de l'école boulle ce qui est intéressant
dans le travail que je mêle c'est
justement de pouvoir mêler du figuratif
et de l'abstrait et le figuratif faisant
référence directement à des images comme
nous connaissons et puis une espèce de
fuite dans un univers abstrait indéfini
improbable qui justement me donne une
liberté une liberté d'imaginer de pensée
pour le spectateur un univers pictural
qui s'inspire de différentes créations
musicales de king crimson robert fripp
ou brian eno est les personnages quant à
eux sont imaginé à partir d'un ensemble
de photographies pour une association
permanente entre imaginaire et réalisme
et viennent de nous retrouver en plateau
claude chose
bonjour bonjour cependant alors on ne
vous présente plus mais tout de même on
rappelle juste que vous êtes le
président de l'union régionale
photographique du sud ouest ile de
france est également l'organisateur du
concours photo en partenariat avec tv
fil 78 vous êtes venu accompagné
aujourd'hui de la lauréate du dernier
concours photo qui avait pour thème un
sourire pour 2016 marie louise bernard
bonjour bonjour et bravo alors non merci
alors je propose tout de suite que nous
découvrions ensemble la sélection des
cinq photos finalistes nous avions donc
en cinquième position soraire malgaches
jugent empire sud est jean pierre simon
en quatrième position le joli bébé
sourire deux bébés en troisième position
un sourire de gori plutôt étonnant
l'animal ou pleines d'eau il fait beau
clin d'oeil appuyé beaux clichés en
seconde position le sourire voilà de
cette très jolie jeune fille et enfin
votre photo marie louise en première
position
cette ravissante petite fille claude
chose un mot pour commenter ces photos
et ce classement
écoutez ce classement il résulte donc
deux de trois 3 personnes qui ont jugé
il ya entre autres votre rédaction et
puis deux autres personnes que je
choisis parmi des méconnaissances
photographique
bon c'est on peut pas dire c'est un
concours qui a rencontré un énorme
succès mais je dirais que il ya eu quand
même des choses simples des jolies
choses c'est quand même globalement
restés dans le classique si vous voulez
on a pas il n'ya pas des choses qui nous
ont foncièrement est sonné dans le tas
dans le dans la vente en gros un peu
plus un peu plus d'une vingtaine images
que nous avons reçues alors soit un
critère est ce qui a été effectué la
sélection par le jury mais le critère ça
a été le joli sourire et on trouve
effectivement des photos de monsieur car
aux frais des ro ciblées qui est un bébé
alors c'est vrai que c'est ce bébé
ciblées il sourit mais on peut dire que
la photo s'il est techniquement n'est
quand même pas
au top c'est un souvenir qui est
personnel pour ce monsieur certainement
pour ces gens si vous voulez mais qui
nous nous touche un peu moins quoi donc
bon voilà le si je reviens sur l'animal
le gorille si vous voulez qu'ils aient
qui sourit je trouve que c'est cette
hauteur là a eu quand même un beau clin
d'oeil ciblées de trouver un animal qui
qui quelque part par les sourires
c'était quoi c'était l'émotion qui
devait se dégager du clae chez swissair
il ya quand même s'ils voulaient cette
émotion de voir ce ce chimpanzé ou
soboriz ces deux journalistes est plutôt
un gorille qui sourient et qui quelque
part si vous voulez quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est je crois que c'est
la seule personne qui je dirais à titre
personnel c'est pas ma surprise si vous
voulez que de voir un animal sourire
donc je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
vous eh bien là c'est voilà alors après
les autres photos donc générer la photo
gagnante de marie-louise mais je crois
que marie d'huy ce sera à même de mieux
en parler je crois qu'il veut à vous de
lui poser la question tout à fait marrer
mu alors expliquez nous déjà dans quel
contexte vous avez réalisé ce cliché ce
que vous avez souhaité exprimer au
travers de l'image voilà qu'on voit à
l'écran écoutez moi j'ai je voyage chez
régulièrement et on peut dire que c'est
un sourire d'une rencontre pendant un
voyage où là aussi c'était une petite
fille dans un village qui avaient encore
le costume traditionnel ça se perd de
plus en plus et je trouvais que c'était
un joli clin d'oeil de montrer cette
petite fille qui qui était intimidé qui
était un peu inquiète et qui à un moment
m'a fait un petit sourire en coin
vraiment comme si un petit sourire de
connivence est bon c'est un merveilleux
souvenir de ce passage dans un village
c'est une rencontre qui vous a marqué
oui oui je m'en souviens parce que j'ai
fait d'autres photos aussi dans ce
village avec des gens très très souriant
et très ouverts en même temps et quelle
émotion vous avez cherché au travers de
ce cliché à à mettre en avant
qu'est ce que c'est là qu'on compte en
fait c'est on vient d'un pays où on va
dans un autre pays on
on a des modes de vie différents et on
al'impression de communiquer par les
yeux et par le sourire et de se dire on
est amis on ne parle pas la même langue
mais on est on est amis oui quand je
vois que vous avez un cadeau pour la
trop longue a ajouté oui comme la
dernière fois on avait en avait offert
si vous voulez un bon d'achat donc un
attaché à favars donc on lui avait
offert pour ça en image bien écouter
cette fois ci le président de la
fédération photographique de france vous
avez dit cher tas souhaité donc doté
cette ce concours et je remets si vous
voulez mais a réduit ce livre donc voilà
qui lui est offert chez ce cas merci
claude pour réaliser un portrait avec
une émotion et un sourire eh bien
écoutez moi je photographie beaucoup de
gens dans la rue et souvent je leur
demande
je demande je vole très très rarement
des photos et je pense que comme un de
mes mentors je vais dire en photographie
m'a toujours fait passer le message que
quand vous posez la question à quelqu'un
mais vous à entrer en communication avec
cette personne et vous allez pouvoir
communiquer avec elle et justement si
vous voulez un moment mais la personne
va il va se passer quelque chose si vous
voulez lucien clergue lisez aussi la
même chose donc l'académicien
photographie qui disait qu' il est
important d'avoir cantons surtout quand
on photographie une femme d'avoir un
contact particulier de façon à un moment
donné mais il va se passer quelque chose
entre le modèle et le photographe donc
je le conseil que je pourrais donner à
nos amateurs ciblées qui nous regarde
bien c'est d'une part de communiquer
avec les gens de la parler d'expliquer
ce que l'on fait et un moment il va se
passer il va se passer quelque chose et
la personne va se détendre et va
retrouver va retrouver si vous voulez
cette émotion parce que un portrait
c'est qu'elle vous regardait tout
toutes les photos de grands photographes
il ya toujours une émotion important de
cibler dans le regard de la personne
comme vous avez pu voir dans l'image de
marie louise comme elles dateraient bien
signifier si vous voulez je crois que
lorsqu'elle est passée dans ce village
est bien en par le sourire bien qu'elle
ne parle pas le là aussi avec la petite
fille ne parlait pas français
il s'est passé quelque chose si vous
voulez entre les deux personnes et c'est
ça qu'il faut savoir choisir saisir avec
son appareil photo
alors je crois également que justement
il faudra savoir saisir l'émotion sur le
village parce que le prochain thème du
prochain concours c'est l'autoportrait
tout à fait alors quand on dira tout
pour tracy s'il vous plaît c'est pas des
selphy pitié parce qu'elle fait un auto
portrait de chacun c'est à ce round
quand vous dire à nos concurrents nous
avons aux auditeurs de faire le choix
s'il voulait de leur image
donc vous avez jusqu'au 7 mars pour
envoyer votre auto portrait / redaction
arobas tv fil 78 points comme on précise
que donc la date a été un petit peu
repoussant donc voilà les mêmes vacances
chacun ait le temps d'envoyer son cliché
et nous accueilleront en plateau on
espère également l'horaire de jours un
concours avec nous le 18 mars prochain
un conseil peut-être pour réaliser un
bon autoportrait je pense qu'il faut
être imaginatif pas forcément prendre un
portrait de soin classique essayer de
jouer derrière un écran derrière un
miroir sans fin avec des artifices ou
faire marcher photo shows poussif et
l'occasion de se regarder du manu votre
mail différentes alors le message est
lancé à votre créativité
marie louise bernard claude chose merci
d'avoir été avec nous en plateau merci
ce bourg de nous accueillir
merci littérature maintenant tout de
suite la sélection du pavé du canal donc
une braise sous la cendre est une
nouveauté en roman adolescents de saba
tahir chez pocket jeunesse
alors on va se retrouver un petit peu
dans la lignée d'un ongle games avec des
héros qui sont des adolescents on est
dans un monde qui ressemble légèrement
au nôtre mais qui a été modifiée ou dont
les règles ont été modifiées en tout cas
entre des élites des castes plutôt
guerrière des gens qui sont réduits en
esclavage voilà ça ça c'est un peu le
cadre de cette histoire
et on va suivre deux personnages un
jeune garçon qui est destiné qu'est
voilà qu'il ya une grande destinée
visiblement une destinée plutôt
guerrière il est pour avoir une vision
un peu paniqué ni les dans la caste des
méchants mais c'est un personnage bien
plus complexe voilà je peux pas trop
vous en dire mais en tout cas il sait
pas s'il manichéen que ça et on va
suivre également le destin d'une jeune
femme qui s'appelle la ja dont le frère
a été enlevé par la caste dominante par
un masque et qui elle va tout faire pour
intégrer ce groupe dominant pour donner
des informations pour pouvoir libérer
son frère
voilà c'est une vision un peu sombre du
monde mais que les ados aiment bien
c'est plein de suspense c'est très bien
écrit qui n'est pas toujours le cas en
littérature adolescente c'est vraiment
un très bon roman 1 2 et maintenant
c'est au tour de sylvie là on a
directrice divine tourisme qui vous
donne dans sa nouvelle chronique saisie
des sorties c'est l'hiver les journées
sont courtes on a tous besoin de gaieté
de musique c'est le moment d'aller
retrouver michel fugain et son groupe
pluri bus qui passe actuellement à
conflans sainte honorine théâtre simone
signoret et vous le redécouvrir et comme
par le passé mais avec des nouvelles
musiques un peu improbable c'est tout
nouveau
c'est extraordinaire il faut en profiter
si on a envie de retrouver michel fugain
c'est vraiment le moment allez le voir à
conflans sainte honorine
comme il fait froid on a envie de rester
à la maison et qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand on reste à la maison pour se
détendre soit en regard tv fils soit on
joue à des jeux de société c'est le
moment de les découvrir au festival
festi ludo qui se déroulent à la salle
du colombier à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
il y à plus de 8
jeux à découvrir ça passe par des jeux
de dés des jeux de cartes des jeux
d'adressé des jeux de culture générale
de plateau toutes sortes de jeux que
vous pourrez découvrir et un animateur
qui vous les fait découvrir vous pourrez
passer une journée en famille ou entre
amis à festi ludot n'hésitez pas c'est
le 23 et le 24 à 14h30
et oui on peut voyager sans bouger de sa
région et nous vous invitons à les
découvrir un spectacle organisé par
lingua rich
il s'agit d'un spectacle sur le nouvel
an russe où vous découvrirez la culture
et les traditions russes donc ce
spectacle vous proposera de vous évader
sans le froid puisque aujourd'hui en
russie il fait extrêmement froid même
encore plus qu'ici donc découvrez ce
spectacle cet extraordinaire et en plus
vous finirez par des pâtisseries du des
pâtisseries russes qui sont complètement
innovante par rapport à ce qu'on a
l'habitude de goûter donc allez vous
évader en russie avec lingway rick à
poissy il y a toujours des
divertissements dans les yvelines et la
saison du cirque reprend avec night
circus du 28 au 30 janvier prochain vous
découvrirez la compagnie hongroise rue
cirque elle cette compagnie allie
tradition et modernité
vous découvrirez leur agilité leur
prouesse mais aussi leur élégance et
vraiment c'est un spectacle fabuleux
pour toute la famille et c'est au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
dans les yvelines
il ya toujours quelque chose à faire
même le soir il y a énormément de lieux
et de motifs pour se cultiver dans les
yvelines nous vous invitons à aller
découvrir le musée maximilien luce qui
se trouve à côté de la collégiale de
menthe à mantes la jolie et dans ce
musée vous découvrirez toutes les
collections du post impressionniste
maximilien luce des oeuvres qui ont été
prêtés par d'autres musées très très
important et également des oeuvres qui
ont été cachés pendant plus de trente
ans et qui sont ressortis spécifiquement
pour cet
exposition qui ont donc lieu à partir du
22 janvier
donc allez découvrir ce formidable
courant du post impressionniste à mantes
la jolie et vous l'avez vu pour sa
chronique celui-là on à se trouver au
château de la madeleine c'est à présent
virginie le vote est directrice
communication du parc de la haute vallée
de chevreuse qui nous présente le site
c'est un très beau château médiéval qui
a la chance de dominer tout le panorama
de la vallée de chevreuse et donc d'être
un site que les gens apprécient beaucoup
parce qu'à la fois il ya cette
magnifique court avec son puits avec
voilà plein de vestiges du passé
une exposition et des caves à visiter à
l'intérieur et puis évidemment la
boutique du parc avec les produits du
terroir qui représente bien voilà toute
la diversité rurales de la vallée de
chevreuse on a une guide conférencière
qui travaille aussi pour le musée de
cluny qui est spécialiste de l'époque
médiévale et qui organise régulièrement
des ateliers donc on aura un atelier
pour les adultes autour de la cuisine
médiévale
donc on va goûter découvrir des épices
les saveurs et préparer des recettes et
les déguster ensemble donc un atelier
destiné aux adultes
et puis aussi des ateliers pour les
enfants autour de la calligraphie voilà
du geste calligraphique et de l'écriture
médiévale qui seront là tous les deux
très prochainement on pourra retrouver
toutes les informations sur le site
internet du parc
et pour votre rubrique cinéma nous
sommes allés chercher vos réactions sur
les nouveautés à la fiche au micro de
fanny bourdillon oui il est pas mal mais
j'aurais aimé que ce soit plus qu est
plus d'aspérités en fait tôt soit moins
lisse par les acteurs super super elle
surtout elle est très très bien
l'actrice j'espère qu'elle aura l'oscar
on verra lui aussi il est bien il ya des
passages un petit peu longuet mais c'est
il ya des moments
on est pas mal il ya un petit peu de le
sentiment aussi disons comme c'est des
jeunes finalement bombe à nous à notre
âge on a mis à voir les jeunes quand
même de mardi il est monstrueux dans ce
film il joue deux rôles il joue le rôle
de son frère qu'est psycho va t il joue
le rôle du gangster oc & c c c super
super super un peu sanguinolent par
moments me go c'est la mafia et pour le
coup de coeur de professionnels c'est
bertrand pigné du cinéma les yeux d'elsa
200 cyr l'école qui vous le donne le
coup de coeur des yeux d'elsa cette
semaine c'est un coup de coeur qui sera
diffusée à partir du 29 janvier c'est à
dire dans deux semaines c'est un film
qui s'appelle blade runner que tous les
grands cinéphiles connaissent que les
jeunes cinéphiles connaissent peut-être
pas en tout cas que ses instincts fine
qui sortit en 82 a encore beaucoup de
spectateurs qui ne leur ont pas vu dans
son format original c'est à dire sur
grand écran et dans sa version directeur
sketchs réalisés par invalides et
finalement par ridley scott
donc ce film nous vous proposons de le
découvrir le 29 janvier au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa lors d' une ciné-conférence
à partir de 20 heures précises
moi même et mon camarade sylvain ibère
qui est enseignant au lycée mansart
prendront le temps de vous parler en
introduction du film et puis si vous en
avez le souhait on prendra le temps
également d'en parler après la
projection du film alors blade runner
c'est c'est un monument un grand rôle de
harrison ford un grand rôle de rugueux
raoult ailleurs probablement le plus
grand film de ridley scott avec alien
c'est une plongée dans un univers
complètement glauque plusieurs
entièrement plus vieux il pleut pendant
tout le film dans une ville complètement
folle avec cette idée que des répliques
ans c'est à dire des humanoïdes
complètement ou extrêmement identique
aux humains vivent parmi nous et
pourrait présenter une menace c'est un
vrai film d'action et en même temps un
film complètement aérien avec la musique
de vangelis qui est absolument
magnifique
le film sera diffusé donc le 29 janvier
à 20 heures
il sera aussi diffusée le dimanche et le
lundi suivant mais vraiment le 29
janvier c'est le moment où on pourra en
parler ensemble je vous attends nombreux
et à très bientôt et avant de se quitter
quelques idées sorties pour votre week
end rendez vous samedi soir 20h30 à la
merise de trappes pour retrouver didier
lockwood et les violons barbares
un voyage virtuose de quatre cordes
frottées de la chine aux balkans et de
la mongolie au moyen orient tout de
suite un extrait
privé
et un autre rendez vous samedi soir
également à 19 heures cette fois ci à la
salle paul gauguin de montigny le
bretonneux
pour la troisième édition du tremplin
rock the choice quatre groupes locaux
s'affronteront pour la finale et enfin
dimanche 25 janvier de 10 heures à 19
heures à la maison des associations de
voisins-le-bretonneux un salon bien-être
vous attend ateliers conférences
expositions et démonstrations autour de
l'art de vivre et de l'épanouissement
personnel et c'est la fin de ce sept
huit week-ends émission à voir et à
revoir sur notre site internet
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous
souhaite un excellent week end